we're told here are the approximate
ratios for angle measures 25 degrees 35
degrees and 45 degrees so what they're
saying here is if you were to take the
adjacent leg length over the hypotenuse
leg length 425 degree angle it would be
a ratio of approximately 0.91 for a 35
degree angle to be a ratio of 0.8 to and
then they do this for 45 degrees and
they do the different ratios right over
here so we're going to use the table to
approximate the measure of angle D in
the triangle below so pause this video
and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together
now what information do they give us
about angle D in this triangle well we
are given the opposite length right over
here let me label that that is the
opposite leg length which is three point
four and we're also given what is this
right over here is this adjacent or is
this a hypotenuse you might be tempted
to say well this is right next to the
angle or this is one of the lines or
it's on the Ray that helps form the
angle so maybe it's adjacent but
remember adjacent is the adjacent side
that is not the hypotenuse and this is
clearly the hypotenuse it is the longest
side is this it is the side opposite the
90 degree angle so this right over here
is the hypotenuse hypotenuse so we're
given the opposite leg length and the
hypotenuse length and so let's see which
of these ratios deal with the opposite
and the hypotenuse and if we let's see
this first one is adjacent and
hypotenuse the second one here is I
potenuse
opposite and hypotenuse so that's
exactly what we're talking about we're
talking about the opposite leg length
over the hypotenuse over the hypotenuse
length so in this case what is going to
be our opposite leg length over our over
our hypotenuse leg length it's going to
be three point four over eight three
point four over eight which is
approximately going to be equal
- let me do this down here this is eight
goes into three point four eight goes
into three eight goes into 34 4 times 4
times 8 is 32 4 I subtract and I could
scroll down a little bit I get a 2 I can
bring down a 0 8 goes into 20 two times
and that's about as much precision as
any of these have and so it looks like
for this particular triangle and this
angle of the triangle if I were to take
a ratio of the opposite length and the
hypotenuse length opposite over
hypotenuse
I get 0.42 so that looks like this
situation right over here so that would
imply that this is a 25 degree 25 degree
angle
approximately